celebs are
taking on the [ __ ] dance challenge and
cardi b
she's here for it on monday
james charles slayed the challenging
choreo
posting this video to twitter now from
the top
make it drop that's some wet that's
something i get a bucket
and a mob that's some wet yeah like i
said
he nailed it i'm talking
[Music]
and cardi took notice retweeting the 21
year old beauty vloggers video
and writing i [ __ ] love it and you
know what else cardi loves
addison rey's mom sherry easterling
doing the challenge too
[Music]
the 40 year old mama didn't hold back
working those moves
like a boss macaroni in a pot
[Music]
cardi shared it on twitter writing
simply period
naturally addison did the wap dance too
and shared her reaction to her mom's
impressive moves on tick tock
with this video admitting in the caption
she went harder than me
[Music]
oh and addison's dad monty lopez
he did it too
[Music]
i would die but as long as it's not my
dad
i'm super here for this family dance
fest i mean i think it's so cool and
they aren't the only ones taking on the
[ __ ] challenge
i don't cook i don't clean but let me
tell you i got this ring
charlie demilio put a remix on the
challenge handcuffs leashes switch my
wig make him feel like a g10 put him on
his knees give him something to believe
in
jason derulo's girlfriend jenna froome's
gave her
all bucky in a mop that's some wet
and lizzo well we'll give her friends an
a for effort get a bucket and a
they hit the beat so hard the phone fell
make it drop that's so wet even cardi
herself
is getting in on the action she tried to
learn the moves during an
insta live
yeah it didn't go so well this dance is
stressing me out
cardi i feel you these moves are so bold
and possibly dangerous that high kick
those splits
guys proceed with caution
oh come on
carter based new song whack wob
w.i.p that's acronym oh
yeah some may argue that the lyrics
could put someone in the hospital too
oh snappy snap snap leslie jordan
blessed us with his reaction to cardi
and meg's not so safe for work song
on instagram alongside the caption i
almost had a heart attack
and he is literally all of us
well that is just shocking